cinco años de los atentados de barcelona
y cambrils este miércoles hubo un
homenaje en el punto donde terminó la
furgoneta con la que se realizaron los
atropellos éstos fueron llevados a cabo
por una decena de miembros de una célula
yihadista
16 personas murieron y 140 resultaron
heridas
y contar con el cuello y la cabeza tenía
todo cristales en los brazos de la
cabeza en el acto también hubo presencia
política de españa cataluña y barcelona
pero al lado de lo institucional se pudo
ver la polarización que todavía vive
cataluña estas imágenes son de una
discusión cuando una víctima reprendió a
manifestantes independentistas por
boicotear el minuto de silencio
o sea cuando una señora que le matan a
su madre en ramblas y que además es
herida grave
escucha proclamas políticas durante
minuto de silencio en homenaje a su
madre
él no entiende nada no soy no sé si
tienes en lugares de momento los
independentistas pedían saber la verdad
un ex comisario español en una
declaración judicial reciente insinuó
sin pruebas que la inteligencia española
quería dar un escarmiento a cataluña el
atentado sucedió en los meses previos al
referendo de cataluña del 1 de octubre
de 2017 sospechamos de mucha gente hay
muy malas intenciones alguien dijo les
vamos a dar un susto se les ha escapado
se les ha escapado ese susto tres de los
perpetradores fueron condenados hasta 53
años el resto de miembros murieron
durante la preparación y la realización
del atentado mientras las víctimas
reclaman que sólo un tercio han sido
reconocidas como tal y han recibido la
indemnización